nos dicen a javier se le pidió
determinar si fx es igual a x menos raíz
cúbica de x es par impar o ninguna aquí
está su trabajo es correcto el trabajo
de javier si no lo es cuál es el primer
paso en donde javier se equivocó muy
bien vamos a resolverlos juntos veamos
primero repasemos qué es lo que trata de
hacer javier él quiere saber si fx es
par impar o ninguna y fx se define como
x menos raíz cúbica de x el primer paso
que realizó javier es encontrar la
expresión df de menos x recordemos que
si f de menos x es igual a fx entonces
es par si efe de menos x es igual a
menos
fx entonces es impar por lo que tiene
sentido que el primer paso sea encontrar
efe de x así que trata de evaluar efe -
x y para hacerlo reemplaza menos x en
cualquier lugar que vea x en fx por lo
que esto es correcto luego
esto es menos x menos el menos x dentro
del radical es una raíz al cubo es lo
mismo que menos 1 por equis y la raíz
cúbica de menos 1 es menos uno por lo
que sacamos ese menos 1 del radical por
lo que esto tiene sentido después hay
menos equis y negativo por negativo es
positivo por lo que esto es correcto y
luego lo que trata de hacer es checar si
efe de menos x es igual a efe x o igual
a efe - x checo si esto era igual a esto
oa esto aquí dice menos x más la raíz
cúbica de x que es lo de aquí arriba no
es igual que fx igual a x menos raíz
cúbica de x definitivamente no es igual
a efe x o menos f x que es igual a menos
x menos la raíz cúbica de x esto se ve
extraño es menos f x que es igual a
menos x menos la raíz cúbica de x - efe
x es igual al negativo de toda esta
expresión que es igual a menos x menos
la raíz cúbica de x por lo que
distribuimos el signo negativo es menos
x más la raíz cúbica de x por lo que
javier calculó mal el negativo de fx
aquí así que no es correcto que menos x
más raíz cúbica de x no sea igual a
menos fx porque si lo es así que se
equivocó acá el error de javier está
aquí evaluado de forma incorrecta - efe
x así que es correcto el trabajo de
javier no si no lo es cuál es el primer
paso en donde javier se equivocó pues es
en el paso 2 la respuesta correcta es
que si es lo mismo que menos f x por lo
que su conclusión debió ser que fx es
impar